bonjour ici jackie chan et même mes amis
je ne me lasse pas de découvrir à quel
point les gens peuvent rechercher des
trucs bizarres sur google et je sais que
ça vous arrive aussi et que ça m'arrive
aussi l'historique je pense bien
évidemment à l'effacer avant chaque
vidéo mais vous qu'en est il de vous
s'il a maintenant j'étais dans ton
historique il se passe quoi eh ben tu es
mal tu es très mal aujourd'hui on est
sur un jeu qui s'appelle idiot point
wind ne le prenez pas mal un contre vous
il ya le début d'une recherche google et
on doit trouver laquelle est la plus
tapé avec mon skill tome qui traduit
bien évidemment très très mal par
exemple à c'est pourquoi les blancs
pourquoi les tigres blancs sont blancs
voilà quand je vous parlais de recherche
étrange je parlais par exemple de ça
pourquoi les rhinocéros sont en voie de
disparition pourquoi les tigres blancs
sedan votre disparition pourquoi les
briques et blanc n'ont pas de chance
soit de fucked mon mec pourquoi les
tigres blancs sont blancs c'est bon à
savoir et non c'est pas ça
pourquoi les rhinocéros blancs sont les
disparitions et non mais bien sûr où
avais-je la tête pourquoi les globules
blancs sont faibles non ben non des
versions pour quoi les tic sur la
disparition et ben voilà on a tout perdu
nickel alors est-ce qu'un est ce qu
angelina jolie est malade
ouais c'est ça et ben alors [ __ ] j'ai
fait le mec après les autres ça prendra
est ce que quelqu'un est là
alors tu as arrêté trop tôt les gens qui
connaissent pas internet
on se moque des vues on est des petits
contes et le mec qui connaît pas dette
et qui pose que des arts google ya
vraiment un gars qui répond à tout le
monde
est ce que quelqu'un est là il est
néanmoins le chemin si ça veut dire si
l'élysée ni one up est ce que quelqu'un
qui montrent pourquoi les gens iraient
sous google tapez est ce que quelqu'un
qui monte paschi sur youtube heures ils
cherchent un gars pour faire des
montages à peut-être peut-être en
théorie pourquoi je suis si fâchés
fatigue et bavard ou assoiffés moi je
dirais fatigué bas vers / br / la
réponse et tu travailles trop bien
entendu alors my mind usb ça c'est une
recherche google de van damme my mind
lyss be my mind mon esprit mon esprit
devient terne un peu glauque à mon
esprit me joue des tours
mon esprit est mieux que celui des
autres mon esprit est beau mon esprit
est manipulée attention alors ça c'est
top recherche google du pc d'un asile
psychiatrique en fait c'est sa foi le
symbole badoit mon esprit me joue des
tours
ah non mon esprit est contrôlé à ses
clous can we have pouvons nous pour vous
d'en avoir des rapports sexuels
pouvons-nous en espagnol et pour
dénoncer l'arrêt de quoi le temps d
enlever sa seule phrase ou chez damart
cuba parce que j'habite et anthony et du
coup dès que je prenais leur revers pour
rentrer chez moi
et bah j'entendais à la haine à l opep
taux d eau les barres
anthony elle est restée dans la tête
merci des touristes pouvez-vous nous
rendre notre balle ou alors pouvez-vous
nous rendre notre obama
c'est pas mal de bons canaux ias-ecc
genre le mec d'espérer un nom c'est
triste alors comment puis-je éviter le
vol d'identité le diabète d'avoir la
grippe payer des taxes en le mec le
fussent ils tombent sur son historique
il est foutu le mec la taxe sur le
patrimoine
on part sur un délire de fraude fiscale
la grève moi je dirais moi je suis un
truc de taksim exception et voilà [ __ ]
mais pas autant comment vos routes et
vos écoles seront construites à votre
avis comment le trottoir sur lequel tu
marches et il construit à ton avis
comment on n'arrête plus que tu casses
pour exprimer son mécontentement est il
payé à ton avis impôts et vidéos
sponsorisées par le gouvernement bien
sûr est ce que les humains peuvent alors
là là on va perdre foi en l'humanité
mais x mines est ce que les humains
peuvent vivre sur mars
oh pas mal quand tu veux être plus qu un
exilé fiscal qui peut être un exilé de
la planète
mais je vous rassure sur mars le
gouvernement mettra en place un système
d'impôt et de taxes
vous pourrez pas aller là bas pour
éviter les impôts est ce que les humains
peuvent manger des glands est ce que les
humains peuvent avoir la rage
oui c'est pour ça que pasteur inventé le
vaccin contre la rage où il veut juger
tant la culture bien sûr on a repensé au
collège et les humains peuvent-ils avoir
des puces moi je pense c'est vivre sur
mars
non même pas allez jean brassard si on
peut avoir des puces maintenant vers
mais non et c'est vrai c'est un vrai
enjeu c'est même pas son regard des
pucerons connais tous nos coûts et les
lentes les bébés des coûts mais les
puces ce qu'on peut avoir des puces il
ya plus de deux mille espèces de puces à
ahmed mais attends mais c'est tout un
match psa le mccafé hélium le bébé et
l'yonne celui-là la merde
celui-là c'est totalement une puce
géante en fait on va après quelques
recherches et une photo de chats mignons
oui on peut avoir des puces c'était
l'instant culture d'art d'une trompette
mais bon et il toxiques de manger des
pommes de terre crue manger une banane
et un oeuf en même temps manger un oeuf
et une banane manger des graines de
pommes pour les enfants cooper qui est
un pommier pousse dans leur corps ouais
quand j'étais petit je pensais ça ouais
de manger un oeuf et une banane sucré
bon clairement clairement manger un oeuf
et une banane aux mots il ya un délire
là je sais pas pourquoi mais il ya un
truc qui va pas aux dires banane avec to
gaza
non juste un incident banal non des
patates cru non des grains de pommes oui
mon dieu si à niort les pépins de pomme
ont un fort goût amer vous le savez la
plupart des mauvais goût dans la nature
servent à nous mettre en garde contre
une substance dangereuse en effet le
pépin de pomme est riche en six années
le cyanure un poison puissant mais j'ai
pas un mais les grains de cyanure par
kilo de masse corporelle suffit à vous
envoyer dans l'autre monde
heureusement même si cela paraît très
peu il vous faudrait manger 143 pépins
de pomme pour atteindre cette dose soit
19 pomme d'un coup à temps mais qu est
ce qu'on est en train d'apprendre qu'il
est possible de se suicider en mangeant
des pépins de pomme got talent est on
apprend les choses avec ces conneries de
recherche google est ce qu'un tatouage
est assez intéressant c'est de faire un
bleu une conclusion oui honte a quand
même exposé la polenta comme trouer la
peau est supposé pellet bas j'espère
lire puisque moi il appelait mon gars
mais plus que joueur de foot quoi fait
pour voiture avec mon jeu là dessus à
chaque vidéo ce qu'un tatouage est un
péché est ce qu'un tatouage vaut le coup
est ce qu'un tatouage est supposé avoir
l'air fade
après cicatrisation âge et 10 d'entre
les gens qui ont une religion et qui
voulait savoir si avoir un tatouage
c'était c'était pêcher ou alors les gens
qui sont fait un tatouage est con et
symptômes je loue et qui veut s'assurer
que tout va bien moi je dirais peu la
merde va empêcher alors bah ouais c'est
un péché c'est ça a jamais vu que je
suis athée je m'étais jamais posé la
question mais franchement j'avoue que
vaut-elle région tu dois te demander de
plus à un truc nouveau tatouage veut
dire au moment où les textes religieux
ont été écrits elle n'est peut-être pas
de tatouage
ce que j'ai dit une connerie peut-être
le premier tatouage se situe en egypte
avec une momie de 2200 avant
jésus-christ au revoir le carbon en tout
cas c'est sûr ça c'était pas démocratisé
comme c'est actuellement le cas on
apprend plein de choses dans cette vidéo
et c'est fou à la base on voulait pas
avant des choses mais qu'est ce que les
filles font est pour ça qu est ce que
les filles font aussi power sleepover
s'est passé nuit loin de chez soi ou
alors chez soi avec un ou deux invités
qu'est ce que les filles font dans leur
lit qu'est ce que les filles aiment de
quoi les filles aiment parler qu'est ce
que les filles veulent lui et lui il est
à bout de souffle
je ne comprends rien à ce système qu est
ce qu elle vole de quoi elle aime parler
giro à merde qu'est ce qu'elle aime et
c'est ça à l'ayguade globalement exact
le même truc que nous et elle aime
autant le jeu vidéo que le cinéma que
le jeu vidéo est ce que la grande
bretagne est une monarchie est en
angleterre et au royaume uni fait partie
du royaume uni fait partie de l'europe
et ce qui m'aide pas est ce que la
grande-bretagne et en angleterre
danseuse a ouai bah voilà c'est ça alors
cet amalgame il est où je pensais que la
grande bretagne c'était la même chose
que le royaume-uni est en fait il ya une
mini différents une grosse différence
quand même c'est que la grande bretagne
c'est une île composé par l'angleterre
l'écossé le pays de galles et le royaume
uni c'est un état composé par les mêmes
pays plus l'irlande du nord pardon de
grande bretagne c'est une zone
géographique et royaume uni c'est un
état tâche allait pas quand je pouvais
ne pas savoir ça j'ai jamais aimé la
joue en même temps le mec est claquée du
cul et la station sert de la dernière on
donne tout ce qu'on a aidez moi je aidez
moi je m'ennuie
aidez moi j'ai accidentellement aidez
moi je suis en vie de fuck besoins des
dents espagnol besoins des dents langage
des signes
oh franchement je pense que c est des
mois j'ai accidentellement en a même un
nom et des mois je m'ennuie non aidez
moi je suis en vie devant soi ça et des
mois en espagnol à l'élever ne les
levées de que personne ne respecte et
bien voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
vidéo bon je pense que les trucs google
on va arrêter avant un moment le maxus
la vie dans une première vidéo il
cherche que les gens cherchent
conditions google puis dans une seconde
vidéo il cherche que les gens cherchent
qu ils ne cherchent pas lui sur google
je l'avais préparé cette phrase n'était
pas aimé la vidéo ça vous a plus que
d'habitude et et continuer de faire des
recherches comme ça google tous les
jours plus improbables les unes que les
autres parce que ce soit très très drôle
et j'espère que vous tomberez jamais sur
les miennes et à bientôt
[Musique]